benoît murat seul président de
l'association action sécurité éthique
républicaine
bonjour et merci d'être avec nous en
direct ce matin sur rtl france alors ce
retrait de la liste noire des
terroristes
ça confirme l'objectif de washington
celle d'en finir avec cette guerre
désastreuse selon les termes de
l'administration by dad bonjour oui
c'est une c'est un pas en avant un pas
positif d'autant qu'il avait été pris
dans la précipitation plus sans doute
pour embêter l'administration byden qui
arrivait au pouvoir mais qui en tout cas
sur le terrain envenimer les choses et
notamment dans les relations avec eux
les associations humanitaires
ce qu'il faut quand même relever c'est
que les combats ont repris très
fortement aujourd'hui au yémen que la
situation humanitaire est encore pire
que celle de 2020 que près de 2 millions
et demi d'enfants de moins de cinq ans
sont en urgence humanitaire et que 400
milles risque de mourir
cette année parce que ce conflit ne
trouve aucune solution et que jusqu'à
maintenant effectivement
l'administration trump mettez de l'eau
sur le feu
systématiquement dans cette région du
monde
et justement on sent bien que
l'administration trucks va c'est à une
reprise les processus politique pour
mettre un terme
maiden pardon l'administration weiden
pour mettre un terme à ce conflit
comment est ce qu'elle peut s'y prendre
elle a déjà fait alors elle arrive elle
a déjà fait un premier pas en enlevant
donc là les outils de la liste de la
liste noire de la liste terrorisme en
blinken lors secrétaire d'état quand
même dit que les individus rester sur
sur une liste
qu'ils gardent eux-mêmes il ya une
certitude c'est que les la france
l'allemagne et les etats-unis ont
condamné l' attaque des outils sur
l'aéroport de ryad
ah bah comme étant un crime
international et on ne les a pas
entendus sur les crimes de guerre et les
crimes contre l'humanité de la coalition
dirigée par l'arabie saoudite et les
émirats arabes unis donc là il ya besoin
d'un véritable rééquilibrage de la part
des pays occidentaux pour montrer que
ils ont vraiment une volonté de trouver
une résolution à ce conflit d'aider à
une résolution à ce conflit parce que ce
conflit ne sera ne trouvera une
résolution qu'avec les acteurs sur le
terrain mais surtout et c'est ce qu'ont
fait les états unis et c'est ce qu'il
faut les états unis pardon et
l'allemagne et c'est ce que doit faire
la france de façon urgente c'est cesser
toute exportation d'armes en direction
des pays de la coalition dirigée pendant
dix huit et les émirats arabes unis pour
en revenir à ce retrait de la liste
noire des terroristes quel impact
concrètement on rate cela aura-t-il
alors concrètement ce ça permet de
descendre de faire descendre la tension
et dans ces cas là c'est extrêmement
important
ça veut dire que les outils se sont ré
se sentent mois sous pression de la part
des états unis
les pays de la coalition l'art dont
l'arabie saoudite et les émirats arabes
unis vont sentir obligé de faire un peu
plus attention à ce qu'ils font ils se
savent un peu plus sur surveillance et
puis mais surtout encore une fois même
si cette décision est importante la
décision la plus importante de
l'administration byden c'est d'avoir
suspendu l'aide militaire auprès d'eux
de l'arabie saoudite et des émirats
arabes unis et d'avoir dit également
qu'ils suspendaient leurs exportations
d'armes en direction de ces pays
il s'agit de voir là encore qu'elles
sont effectivement quel type d'armes
seront effectivement suspendus jeu
justement vous pensez que d'autres pays
pourraient emboîter le pas aux états
unis et prendre la même décision
alors la question s'est posée pour les
britanniques parce que les britanniques
continuent aussi d'envoyer des armes et
a priori l'administration johnston
répond aurait répondu négativement mais
il y a en grande bretagne de nombreux
parlementaires qui poussent à cette
décision de suspension des exportations
d'armes plus les ong 4 à redéposer une
action judiciaire pour demander la
suspension de ses exportations d'armes
pour la france c'est aussi ce devrait
être aussi une une décision logique mais
on sait qu'on a un président république
qui prend des décisions seul sans avoir
de connaissances au niveau des relations
internationales ni au niveau de ce que
peut être une guerre
et là c'est un déficit est terrible
parce que les organisations des nations
unies disent que la situation donc
empire aujourd'hui et qu'en plus il ya
un sous financement de l'aide
humanitaire au yémen et insoumise et
lancement ça veut dire que des gens des
enfants des adultes vont mourir parce
qu'ils ne peuvent ni avoir accès à l'eau
ni avoir accès aux soins et que cette
décision perdure au pub maintenant plus
presque six ans là quand on voit que la
france par exemple a vendu pour 17
milliards d'euros d'armes à l'egypte
l'egypte les et la rabine et les émirats
arabes unis
buts en 10 ans on se dit qu'il ya
quelque chose qui ne fonctionne pas dans
le royaume de france
merci beaucoup en tout cas bonne à murat
ciel d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes président de
l'association action sécurité éthique
républicaine